[Music]
this show that you're doing now is such
a different experience I would imagine
from all those years on CERN out live
how are you adapting how is it different
it is it is different I'm adjusting
decently you know on SNL you just lock
on cards and there's multiple cameras
but you don't ever feel them because
you're just on your cards and you talk
talk talking on this
we're actually have a bunch of cameras
going and you know you got to sort of
act through the scenes and I keep
finding myself thinking that I'm turning
dramatically and then looking straight
down a camera so just what the one rule
you're not you're not supposed to look
at the lens yeah yeah it's bad so you
know I'll be interrogating you and be
like you know you're busted so deal with
that now eight year what about like I
would think one of the fun things about
playing a cop because always just been a
big kid is action scenes you get to run
around you get to have a gun yeah you
get to do all the stuff that it's sort
of a wish fulfillment when you were a
kid you dream about having a job like
that 100% thank you for bringing this up
actually cuz I've been sort of pushing
to do more action and they're a little
skeptical because I keep looking into
the camera and it's expensive to do
action so I was thinking if you wouldn't
mind I was gonna do a little action demo
here to prove that I can pull it off and
not look at the camera
[Music]
that gun that's always there yeah
that's that's there for my protection
yeah it's like a first aid kit yeah okay
well you gonna tell us what you're gonna
do or so I'm gonna do just a classic I
always wanted to do this this is what
I'm pushing for just run and slide while
shooting avoiding the lens avoid the
lens joy yeah and we'll see how it goes
you want a little music drumroll
anything that would be killer yeah if
you guys give me some action here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's ready to pick you going
what uh that was I think you fired 800
rounds in that clip to do look good I
think you looked pretty good I don't
think you hit the land let's take a look
okay this again in slow-mo whoa that's a
great slide
my foot gets gonna [ __ ] behind my own
every in a very erotic position like
more of a common I was gonna say it's an
ancient lovemaking position you were in